we have a real equipment problem the way
we needed missiles in world wars we need
ventilators New York State is preparing
its guidance for doctors and hospitals
on how to make some difficult decisions
about patient care that they may soon
face
New York's Governor Andrew Cuomo says
the state has about 5,000 ventilators
but needs 30,000 ventilators or machines
that aid breathing many critically ill
coronavirus patients like those with
pneumonia need the assistance to survive
so and when hospitals run out of
ventilators how would they decide which
patients take priority
doctors want guidance samuel corvatz is
a philosophy professor and longtime
member of the New York State Task Force
on life and the law in 2015 a group of
experts on behalf of New York state
created guidelines for allocating
ventilators should there be a shortage
of them in a flu pandemic Corbett says
he's seen a draft of the guidance the
state is developing for ventilator
allocation during a corona virus crisis
he says the draft he saw may be
different from the final version New
York's Department of Health says that
while the Department has sought input
from a variety of medical and ethics
experts there's no expectation of a
formal report the guidance that is being
developed and I believe soon will be
promulgated within New York State will
indicate that there will have to be
[Music]
committees triage committees that will
be required to contain representation of
ethical perspectives triage committees
were a key part of the 2015 guidelines
tasks among other things with
determining a patient's level of access
to a ventilator
there will be committees that will be
involved in making the tragic triaging
decisions in situations in which
somebody who needs a ventilator will be
denied access or perhaps somebody on a
ventilator
whom the prospects are essentially
hopeless will have to be removed to make
room for somebody else for whom the
prospects are very much better
so this committee would be empowered to
take a ventilator away from someone
who's alive who probably won't live and
but he's still alive
take them off life support so they can
give it to someone else that's what is
going to happen the 2015 guidelines say
there may be scenarios in which the
triage committee must remove a
ventilator from a patient whose health
is not improving the idea would be the
critical care team would say here's the
decision we believe we have to make and
here's the reason why and we're running
that by a triage review team for vetting
and are we leaving out anything are we
missing anything is there any
consideration that you would call to our
attention and the team might say yeah
you're failing to take into account less
and such or you've missed that or the
committee might say that that seems like
a heartbreaking but justified choice and
the critical care doc at that point
would be empowered to proceed Gourevitch
says he expects that family members of
the patients whose ventilator is set to
be removed would be informed beforehand
you the family member might at that
point say I will not accept this you
would then be told if it says I expect
you have a right of appeal but this all
will play out on a scale of minutes not
hours in the 2015 guidelines appeals are
limited to so-called technical and
justices like for example a withdrawal
decision being made without considering
all triage criteria if it's a hospital
system they might be able to have a
committee that would look over you know
several hospitals
dr. Tiye Pal helped lead the working
group that wrote the original guidance
document in 2007 in working on
guidelines like this I never ever
thought we would get there and now it
definitely is a realistic possibility
dr. Powell says that within the past
week she too has read a draft of the
guidance New York State is preparing
these crisis standards of care it's a
radically different than what we do
normally would temporarily make it
possible to say we're so sorry we tried
to pull you through it didn't work and
now we're going to remove that
ventilator and it would go to some other
person in line an effort to save you is
done and we have people waiting so we're
not gonna continue treating you with the
ventilator and then who makes that call
so that would be the triage committee
we'll evaluate people at 48 hour
intervals Corbett says hospitals could
as a last resort
use a randomization process such as a
lottery to decide distribution there are
some circumstances I know you all
thought of this when discretion doesn't
really play that much of a role the best
you can do is a lottery yes and in fact
the guidelines do allow for lottery you
have to be clear and explicit and
operationally rigorous about how the
lottery is to be done Vietnam will be
horrible for whoever doesn't win the
lottery
New York's Department of Health declined
to comment on any particular policies it
may be considering all this is just so
wildly unpleasant even contemplates and
discuss it is exactly that it is
searingly difficult even to have to
think about it